il ya quelques mois je vous publié une
faq qui avait pour titre faut-il choisir
son smartphone par son opérateur oui ou
non et je donnerai une réponse un peu
bref moi je préfère effectivement acheté
mon téléphone nu parce que s'ils cassent
si du coup je dois en racheter un c'est
pas pris d'assurance
eh bien ça m'embête de voir toujours
payer l'autre avec mon opérateur dans
tous les cas je préfère avoir un
abonnement moins cher qui correspond
vraiment un mésusage 15 euros 20 euros
maxi par mois mais vraiment maxi maxi à
10 ou 15 euros par mois déjà on retrouve
un forfait qui est très bien qui marche
parfaitement bien en france même des
fois à l'étranger et vous achetez votre
téléphone nu qui correspond à votre
budget abruzzes âge et les trucs sont
très bien tous les jours depuis j'ai
voulu approfondir la question parce que
c'est un peu plus complexe et on va se
reposer la question la base
faut-il acheter son smartphone par son
opérateur oui ou non est ce une bonne
affaire on va tous détaillé et à la fin
vous aurez la réponse tranchée clair et
net mais avant toute chose on est
toujours en période de confinement
moment où je tourne cette vidéo je vous
demande depuis le début du conflit
demande vous voyez vos vidéos savoir
comment ça se passe chez vous on va donc
se regarder la vidéo du jour est le
monsieur breux filmant dire que tout va
bien pour moi de mon côté de youtube
netflix
je regarde beaucoup tes vidéos sur
youtube qui m'ont aidé à choisir mon
téléphone ya un an donc
s10 plus alors voilà plutôt remercier ce
que tu fais un grand tu fais tu laisses
un grand choix de sélection correctement
les téléphones chez très bonne
présentation du groupe bigard pas toi
maintenant tout va bien de ton côté tu
as you merci de m'avoir envoyé cette
vidéo on va faire un tour derrière je
vais tous vous détailler vous expliquer
et on va voir au final c'est intéressant
d'acheter son smartphone par son
opérateur
oui ou non avant toute chose je veux
apporter deux informations essentielles
la première c'est que cette vidéo vaut
pour la france puisque je ne connais pas
le marché que soit le marché belge le
marché algérien le marché marocain
tunisien le marché anglais le marché
américain canadien je ne les connais pas
donc cette vidéo ne vaut que pour le
marché français il ya en plus une vraie
spécificité française
de plus on aime bien être un peu
spécifique un peu bizarre un peu a pas
bien c'est qu'en fait en france ce qui
n'est pas le cas dans le monde entier
peut-être dans quelques pays mais pas
énormément
en france on achète à peu près à 80% nos
smartphones voire un peu plus par
opérateurs et non pas des smartphones
donc la question se pose encore plus
est-ce qu'il faut continuer ou alors
est-ce qu'il faut l'acheter à part
prendre un forfait de l'autre côté donc
du coup la question vaut vraiment le
coup d'être posée pour répondre à cette
question il nous faut des feuilles
blanches incarner des stylos énormément
lors n'est pas mal nous aujourd'hui si
on va se baser sur le fait qu'on veuille
acheter par exemple le dernier
smartphone haut de gamme de samsung en
tout cas un des derniers smartphones
haut de gamme de samsung
que serait ici le galaxy s 20 il coûte
en prix 9 c'est à dire nu si vous étiez
hors forfait 909 euros sans sa config de
base version 4g et on va se prendre
l'exemple si on acheter ici par un
opérateur peut importe l'opérateur en
ces détails qu'on peut retrouver
quasiment partout en tout cas très
similaire à 349 euros 90 ça c'est tarif
nu à cela il faut rajouter plus 8 euros
par mois pendant 24 mois ce qui vous
fait donc en plus 192 euros soit un
total de 541 euros 90 pour acheter votre
smartphone par votre opérateur
donc quand on regarde comme ça
effectivement c'est sans appel il ya une
vraie différence mais ça c'est sans
prendre en compte le tarif du forfait
j'ai pris galaxy s devant un exemple
simple voir naître en othe peu un paon
va se baser sur cette idée là si vous
voulez acheter un smartphone à 500 euros
600 euros ça changera pas grand chose
par rapport à une l'idée globale qu'on
va pouvoir se faire effectivement le
tarif sera un peu plus bas mais ce qu'on
va
pas réussi à réellement ce sont les
tarifs des forfaits voilà comment on va
procéder
on va venir regarder ici toute la partie
forfait et on va se laisser pas réussi
en trois parties une première partie qui
sera un forfait sans smartphone c'est à
dire que vous achetez votre smartphone
nu ici vous avez un forfait avec le
smartphone dont vous allez le payer
moins cher et on va se positionner ici
les forfaits qu'on appelle les forfaits
low cost pour la petite info je suis
parti sur un forfait 50 gigas appels sms
mms illimités en france métropolitaine
dans l'union européenne et vers les dom
donc j'ai pris les forfaits qui sont
vraiment semblable avec quelques
ajustements bien évidemment entre les
différents opérateurs
en règle générale les forfaits sans
smartphone sont des forfaits 12 mois
sauf que nous ici on va être calculée
sur 24 mois pour vraiment avoir des
bases de comparaison les tarifs que je
vous prends qui sont des choses que j'ai
relevé chez les opérateurs
j'ai pris quelque chose qui me semblait
en tout cas somme toute assez
représentatif qu'on pourra se faire une
idée on va commencer ici si vous achetez
votre smartphone à part dans ce que j'ai
repéré vous allez payer votre abonnement
à 29 euros 99 par mois et sur 24 mois ça
vous fera la jolie somme de 719 euros 76
rien que pour votre forfait ça veut donc
dire que là vous allez rajouter en plus
les 909 euros de votre smartphone ça
vous donnera un total à 1628 euros 76
si vous prenez votre smartphone avec
votre forfait vous allez payer votre
abonnement un peu plus cher vous allez
le payer 39 euros 99
vous multipliez sa part 24 mois ça vous
donne 959 euros 76 mais ici par contre
votre smartphone vous allez le payer
beaucoup moins cher 541 euros 90 dont
convient les reporter ici plus 541 euros
90 ce qui nous donne un total sur 24
mois donc sur deux en 2005 101 euros 66
ce qu'ils fassent moins intéressant là
dessus c'est que si vous avez acheté
votre smartphone avec votre opérateur
donc avec votre forfait et bien vous
allez payer le total beaucoup moins cher
soit 24 mois que si vous achetez votre
smartphone eu et que vous prenez un
forfait à part vous avez quand même un
écart de 127 euros
mais ça c'était sans compter sur les
forfaits low cost il fait partie sur un
forfait à 15 euros par mois x 24 mois
sam dunn 360 euros auxquels je vais
rajouter les 909 euros de mon smartphone
sommes fin totale à 1269 euros sur 24
mois est donc là c'est sans appel vous
voyez que si j'achète mon smartphone nu
avec un forfait classique à part ça me
coûte quand même très cher si j'achète
mon smartphone par mon opérateur sur un
forfait standard ça me coûte un peu
moins cher
si par contre j'achète mon smartphone nu
et que je prends un abonnement low cost
à 15 euros par mois
sensiblement équivalents à ceux là eh
bien je me retrouvais un taille haie
fait quand même beaucoup moins cher de
1269 euros donc ça vous voyez c'est la
base mais les opérateurs cherchent à
réagir à réfléchir et à proposer un peu
mieux alors bien évidemment chaque
opérateur propose aujourd'hui sa version
low cost néanmoins il cherche à aller
plus loin pour réussir à convaincre sur
des forfaits un peu plus en art et vous
allez voir que des choses qui sont
vraiment extrêmement intéressant si vous
gardez votre numéro de téléphone
et bien vous allez payer beaucoup moins
cher que vous preniez un forfait sans
smartphone vous allez donc payer 14
euros 99 par mois la première année et
la deuxième année vous allez passer à 29
euros 99 ce qui fait donc ici vous allez
payer un total de 530 9 euros 76
ah ça vous allait rajouter toujours vos
909 euros de smartphones et ça vous
coûtera 1448 0,76
on a déjà gagné quasiment 200 euros si
vous prenez votre forfait avec
smartphone ça va vous coûter 24 euros 99
par mois la première année puis 39 euros
99 par mois la deuxième année ça vous
fera donc au total 2 779 euros 76
vous rajoutez bien évidemment le prix de
votre smartphone qui vous coûte toujours
ici 541 euros 90 vous êtes donc à 1321
euros 1,66 donc 100 euros son offre de
bienvenue puisque vous conservez votre
numéro de téléphone ça veut dire que
vous venez d'un autre opérateur et vous
allez vers cet opérateur là ils vous
font donc des remises mais malgré tout
vous êtes toujours beaucoup plus cher
que si vous partiez sur un forfait low
cost qui lui par contre toujours 1969
euros mais les opérateurs sont malins et
n'ont pas dit leur dernier mot
puisqu'ils ont encore une carte secrète
dans leur manche c'est celle de la boxe
puisque vous le savez les opérateurs
téléphoniques vous vendre des forfaits
téléphone mais également des forces
internet et c'est peut-être là que se
trouve vraiment la solution la plus
intéressante puisque ces tarifs là sont
pas particulièrement extrêmement
intéressant on va recourir ça et on va
partir sur une autre réflexion le fait
de dire vous êtes déjà client box vous
avez des offres du haut ont donc là j'ai
un truc intéressant si je prends mon
smartphone apparaît que j'ai donc un
forfait seul mais je suis déjà
lyon boxe est bien la première année je
vais donc pas payé au forfait à 29 euros
99 je vais le payer 9 euros 99
la première année puis 24 euros 99 la
deuxième année ce qui fait que ça me
fait un total à 419 euros 76 auquel j'ai
venir ajouter bien évidemment les 909
euros de mon smartphone et là ça me sort
tarifs à 1328 euros 76 je suis toujours
plus cher que ce que j ai qu'un forfait
low cost néanmoins je me rapproche tout
doucement si maintenant vous achetez
votre smartphone avec votre opérateur
là ça va pas vous coûter 9 99 plus de 99
ça va vous coûter 19 euros 99
la première année puis 34 euros 99 la
deuxième année ce qui vous fait un total
à 659 euros 75 auquel vous allez venir
ajouter les 541 euros 90 de votre
smartphone ça vous fait donc un total de
1200 1 euro virgule 65 et là ça devient
extrêmement intéressant parce que vous
allez payer le tout beaucoup moins cher
soit 24 mois 1200 en euros 65 contre
1200 69 euros en passant par un forfait
low cost ça veut donc dire que plus je
suis fidèle et plus je suis récompensé
c'est pas une belle mentalité ça ça
c'est la base
il se peut que vous retrouviez des frais
de carte sim de l'ordre à peu près de 10
euros une première fois lorsque vous
allez prendre votre carte sim pour que
ce soit intéressant il faut aussi que le
prix de votre box par mois soit
compétitif par rapport à ce que vous
pourriez retrouver en concurrence donc à
toute une étude à faire de ce côté là ça
sera peut-être l'objet d'une vidéo
comment choisir son forfait internet
d'ailleurs dit moi maintenant si ça vous
intéresse
est ce que vous voulez que je fasse une
vidéo pour vous dire comment choisir
votre forfait bbox pro bleu marqué dès
maintenant en bas en commentaire quand
je vous parle du prix du smartphone 1
909 euros
bien évidemment j'ai pris un smartphone
très haut de gamme un des derniers de
samsung vous pouvez aussi trouver des
smartphones beaucoup moins cher qu'ils
vont bien évidemment faire diminuer
l'addition non pas du côté du forfait
mais du côté du smartphone il y à aussi
de temps en temps des tarifs de
lancement des offres
reprise et puisque je vous parle d'offre
de reprise pourrait faire vous reprendre
votre smartphone ce qui fera également
diminué l'addition un smartphone qui
pourra ensuite potentiellement être
reconditionnés donc on rentre dans un
cercle vertueux ça c'est plutôt bien
et est-ce que je vous parle de
reconditionner vous pouvez également par
votre opérateur
acheter un smartphone reconditionnés un
smartphone qui a déjà vécu et tout ça
dans un contact plus écoresponsable donc
à pas mal de levier à actionner pour
acheter un smartphone par un opérateur
et qu'au final ça vous coûte moins cher
que si vous lâchiez nu avec un
abonnement low cost mais pour ça il faut
accepter de mettre tous ses oeufs dans
le même panier en tout cas pendant une
période de 24 mois puisque rien ne vous
empêche au bout des 24 mois de tout
changer parce qu il se peut que vous
trouviez des offres intéressantes à ce
moment là à la concurrence en tout cas
c'est ce que je pourrais vous conseillez
trouver le package le plus intéressant
aujourd'hui et regarder ensuite dans
deux ans si c'est toujours aussi
intéressant oui ou non et pourquoi pas
ce moment-là venir négocier avec votre
opérateur
il ya un point qu'on en considération
lorsqu'on veut acheter son smartphone 9
je vous prends l'exemple d'un smartphone
qui coûte 909 euros il faut avoir la
tréso et l'argent disponible pour sortir
909 euros alors bien évidemment on va
acheter un smartphone en fonction de ses
possibilités
néanmoins certains opérateurs vous
permettre de les acheter avec des
facilités de paiement se fera donc moins
d'argent à sortir d'un coup ça peut être
une bonne méthode pour vous permettre
d'acheter un smartphone plus facilement
même si au bout du compte vous allez
quand même payer et le deuxième point à
prendre en considération qui est
extrêmement important c'est que si vous
êtes engagés sur 24 mois que vous avez
acheté votre smartphone par votre
opérateur et que vous payez vous 8 euros
par mois et bien si au bout je dirais 2
1 en 6 mois ou peu importe vous casser
votre smartphone cette somme est due
vous allez devoir la payer jusqu'au bout
à ce moment-là vous faudra acheter un
smartphone nu probablement moins cher
mais quoi qu'il en soit vous êtes
engagés et vous ne pouvez pas vous
désengager puisque tout engagements pris
doivent être respectés
néanmoins à la loi chatel qui vous
permettra à partir du 12ème mois de
résider votre forfait en payant 25% des
sommes dues restantes mais si vous
achetez un smartphone nu avec un forfait
low cost vous pouvez partir quand vous
le voulez changer votre forfait au
moment où vous le souhaitez
si vous prenez un forfait standard chez
un opérateur et vous achetez votre
smartphone a pas vous êtes engagés sur
12 mois
au bout de 12 mois vous pouvez donc
résilier votre forfait est partagée sur
notre opérateur si vous souhaiter à vous
de me dire maintenant vous ce que vous
en pensez en va en commentaire est ce
que vous voulez d'autres vidéos comme ça
pour venir vous aider à trouver le bon
forfait de smartphones le bon forfait de
boxe est ce que ça vous intéresse que je
vous donne des astuces des tuto pour vos
idées
mark et moi tout ça bien évidemment en
bas en commentaire sur ce je vous
embrasse que je de rendez vous
extrêmement rapidement parce qu'à plein
de choses qui arrivent et croyez-moi
lèves tu vas être extrêmement chargé ou
des bijoux de l'amour a très vite tao
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mutare